[Music]
kid
start turning buttock and put on your
church shoes little sister because we're
about to blast off what is it you're
trying to say we're going on the
Internet
[Music]
it's the most beautiful miracle I've
ever seen
welcome to the search bar what can I
help you find today umbrella
Umbridge ooh mommy no no is that no
doubt no it's from Reaganomics Urban
Outfitters cool pretty sure he's just
trying to guess what you're gonna sell
my auto failure to touch aggressive
today let me try take me to a web site
that's super intense and really nuts
oh I'd only found one result come on
cartoon characters
you're coming with us
hi ladies I'm a princess - what kind of
a princess are you huh do you have magic
hair no magic hands
no do animals talk to you no or you fall
is no cursed no kidnap to enslave no are
you guys okay police do people assume
all your problems got solved because a
big strong man showed up breaks the
internet shouldn't be rough Rex the
Internet
yes since he is wreckit-ralph uh yeah
but break the Internet
it's like a thing right it's just wreck
seeing it kind of sounds better doesn't
it you're not wrong
you